well um black built today
yeah i can see that um well update mike
this is from this morning an
update on our friend
eric stolen valor i did see this
eric namer another foia request now
obviously i'm
just going to say what i thought this
morning obviously this is just going to
say the exact same thing
that the other foyer requested right
real vague just disenrolled
on it all right it's the same thing
they're not going to expound on eric
nimmer's record
or provide any new information correct
well here's the thing mike
just a photocopy of what they sent chuck
right
it's not going to reinforce anything
subject your freedom of information act
uh request file this response
this response to your january 29 2019
freedom of information request
for the records about eric douglas
nimmer
now i believe that's the the the nimmer
in question yes that is the nimmer that
is the
question quite some time uh the lying
nimmer
uh we initiated a search of the files
maintained by the manpower management
records and performance branch the mmrp
mmrp confirmed that mr nimmer has
never served on active duty
as a member of the us marine corps or
u.s
marine corps reserves
ah you sit get us
pinkies out [ __ ] you see that really
good pinkies out
[ __ ]
and then the rest goes into you know
what you need what you could do i mean
the rest doesn't really matter
well guys i'd say now's a nice time to
point out
just like i was my theme my running
theme last night on nightwave is that um
you know what i totally keep saying that
me and royce are bad guys
the difference is we've never denied
that from day one you're right we're bad
people
but we've told you we're bad people
when are these guys going to start
admitting that they're bad people
because the only difference i see
between guys like me and royce
and guys like owen benjamin and eric
nimmer is that we don't hide what we are
from you
they're two different people there's who
they are when they're uh
doing their live streams and selling
dreams to boomers
giving them hope porn good name for a
show yeah selling dreams to boomers
so these [ __ ] boomer bucks for
youtube cucks
i understand how much more wholly
unlikeable royce and i
are we are we're just not likable guys
but we've
it's that's not it's it's not it doesn't
hurt our feelings because he said that
isn't equality that we we work on
that's a good point it's like saying i'm
not in good shape i know
because i don't do anything i'm aware i
don't go to the gym
right um but you can't say guys
we might be wrong but we're not lying
but it turns out
we're both right and not lying
um and we have paperwork from the
federal government to tell us so
bam